what up peeps we're gonna watch the bad
batch
episode eight today easily this is our
most
viewed show that we cover on youtube
gangbusters
weekly slow down guys geez you're gonna
break youtube
demand this is enormous we can't do
three a week okay they only release them
one at a time oh guys
slow your roll no we're uh we're
enjoying the show though
yeah it could be one thing it was like
how many people were watching this
and we don't i would say still to
subscribe and click that notification
bell hit like buttons
take us on patreon where we got
full-length watch alongs for this i'll
cover a bunch of other shows over there
at the same tier highlights and watch
along included for them as
well pulling the watch all means sync up
with the time code by the way thanks to
berthom chandler for hustling to get
these out for us
you're a good man for thumb really
enjoying getting to know you
anywho let's watch this episode of the
bad badge
big shell scrappers on bronco reported a
power search on a jedi cruiser
it's clone force 99. i have no
interest in a group of rogue clone
deserters if you find them on broker
terminate them but they have omega
that's something you need
[Music]
bracha is the planet from fallen order
there's tons of live ordinance buried in
this shipyard
if you trip one you need to know how to
disable it
seems simple enough well if you're so
sure disarming
me but i only watched you 10 seconds
till we're both goners
ten this connects to the transmitter
[Music]
oh boy three two
one obviously not that one
you think i let you train with a live
explosive
i'm not crazy
how'd the test go i don't want to talk
about it
cheer up kid with my help you'll be a
pro
in no time wrecker tried killing her
last episode
now it only pretends to try that's
progress it's character growth
we've got eyes on us yeah i see them
yeah it's that big light it's that big
obvious thing in the
foreground you ready waiting on you
oh crap guys
oh no you don't
[Music]
oh
that's not comforting
oh and he's dead
hey i i was just waiting to make my move
scrapper guild we should leave in our
present situation we need
money and we have a chance to make a lot
of it right here what's the potential
hall inside this cruiser
my scans indicate the armory and
artillery bay have not been fully
offloaded
just a few of those weapons should clear
our deck with sid
i would also add that the intel from the
bridge's central system has the
potential to be worth far more than any
weapon
ah not to me
[Music]
ricker you're gonna like this
you think that's great check this out
[Music]
ah there you go the power's back on
yeah we can see that
proton torpedoes oh come here beautiful
[ __ ] oh that thing's gotta be covered in
generations of space dust
how's it looking whoever scuttled this
ship didn't wipe the hardware's data
imprint
what's gonna go wrong right now what was
the wall like
it was a primary mission objective
comprised of battles on various fronts
it's a big building where generals meet
why is this button blinking uh-oh that's
the proximity sensor it signals when
there's an approaching vessel
most likely a short circuit
we've got company i think the scrapper
patrol
got a message out it's the empire
ah i will have to call upon further
resistance
we already have someone handling matters
as long as one of these bounty hunters
deliver the young clone intact
that is all that should concern us
[Music]
there's an end game with omega
oh reunion
he won't be able to detect us i'm
blocking their scanners
that won't stop him he knows us
from the inside out i don't know what
else has you seen crosser yeah
any life signs on board can't tell the
scanner's not working
there's too much atmospheric
interference no
you're being jammed they're still on
board
take a shuttle and find their ship yes
commander
oh you got to get across here in one of
those machines yeah
let's get the thing out
oh my god he could be a double agent
they'll do a forward to aft
sweep we can alternate corridors come on
i'm trying to tap into the regs calm so
we can monitor their movements
i'm in push the targets towards the
hangar we'll cut through the artillery
deck or crosshair knew they would hack
in there
he's two steps ahead he can anticipate
their every move
[Applause]
and reroute reserve power to the cannons
if these cannons fire this whole deck
will collapse
i'm counting on it why come after us
you're cheaters
he's obsessed with you crosshair wake
up you're being controlled by an
inhibitor chip he's telling the truth
you can't help it aim for the kid oh
what
my dude online in three two
one
nice nice way to go omega
sounded like a wilhelm scream i wasn't
it's close
victory
the iron engine chamber what you bring
us here
because this is our alternate egress off
the cruiser
i don't even know what that means
there's no sign of them sir they're
avoiding the choke points bring a
shuttle to the artillery deck
get to the bridge and wait for my orders
i didn't think you meant we'd be
escaping through the engine
i could not have been clearer
[Laughter]
i've never been inside an ion engine
it'd be before if you had these chambers
are quite the engineering marvel this
blast primer coating is capable of doing
it uh never star wars fancy wood care
[Laughter]
well now what
try again hunter i told you before
you're surrounded double back
what is that sounds like the engine's
coming online
oh i was worried about that
just when i was like oh good when i
access the central system
which means the engines can be activated
oh no how much heat can these withstand
how much time do we have i estimate less
than two minutes
can we use the explosives from the
armory to disable the engine we place a
series of charges around this cone
we may be able to break away from the
cylinder while destabilizing the core
you have less than two minutes everyone
take an explosive
text omega up top with me oh
boy good thing they got all that so much
for making that money
[Music]
joey you guys would be great basketball
players
yeah the imperial globetrotters
engage
everybody get down
ha knocked his helmet off oh dang
turn the engine off
maybe they fried the chip i wonder
overheat it commander commander can you
hear me we need a medic
they're headed for their ship stop them
what happened to them well
someone's here this wasn't the
scrapper's handiwork
one much work
[Music]
oh damn get behind me
it's a cat bane
a cat right yeah i know his last name is
bait
i've taken down so many clones over the
years
once you figure out one the rest are
easy
you're in for a surprise i doubt that
he's a bounty hunter and you
smart the kids got it all figured out
you're in trouble now man yes
now hand her over she's with us
she's not going anywhere that's
unfortunate
for you
[Music]
wait who hired him and said sid send him
[Music]
or was it the prime minister
oh
oh no
[Music]
damn he's banged up yeah
[Music]
oh whoa
oh man
[Music]
what a shot yeah these last few minutes
yeah
he took omega oh cross hair
no a bounty hunter
we have to find her
omega didn't even run off and do
anything on her own nah
she was like stood by everybody this
whole time man
she behaved herself
wow yeah those last few minutes
right when they were in the engine that
was really really good stuff yeah
cad bane
i'm trying to remember now did he die
i thought he was like presumed dead
the last i remember was no
however he's alive okay he clearly
wasn't
actually dead if he looked dead
i thought i i can't remember supposed to
be like led to believe he died
no i remember he's kind of served me
incorrectly but he's a cool he's a
really cool bounty hunter character for
sure
all right okay no look i looked it up
and i see why i was getting confused
all right so there was supposed to be
there's like um
a big part of what made the final season
of the clone wars exciting was because
before that ever came out there was like
on they had like
early animation concept visuals and
stuff like that
for what was supposed to happen when
they thought clone wars was over before
they announced season seven
and one of the arcs dealt with cad bane
and boba fett which did not see the
light of day
brought back to life in the final season
but there is like videos on youtube you
can watch
of like some of that like storyboards
and stuff
there's like actual animation it's not
complete okay but
yeah it was like the ideas that you're
supposed to see for it
because yeah i don't like the clone wars
the final season wasn't that long
and i i don't remember that arc being in
there so
from uh now i'm remembering that uh yeah
that was supposed to be an arc that but
they didn't ultimately do it like boba
fett
and it was like between boba fett and
him young boba fett obviously
so yeah that's why my mind was like wait
a minute did he die but i was
remembering
that that episode didn't even it didn't
even become a full episode
yeah yeah yes okay and now cad bane
lives on
cad bane lives on he's a really cool
he's like a badass bounty hunter
character he usually works with like
other people
like unlike other bounty hunters uh he's
usually like he's really good at uh
i don't know leading a team of bad
people
okay so he's not your standard i work
alone today yeah i guess the word would
be like uh
delegating he's really good at
delegating okay yeah so
um anyway he's a really badass character
and it's cool that he's here uh
and it looks like i like that he
succeeds right away yeah reintroduction
here in the show
and that just means we're gonna
definitely see more of him now
but okay or i'm a little confused is
that
they the prime minister from camino
dispatched uh cross hair and
um i constantly say cross hair across
hairs which one is it
i don't know why i i keep forgetting if
it's cross hair across hair
isn't it cross hair i'm always second
guessing like a name all the time
anyway but yeah they had i i'm trying to
uh
remember like the prime minister he
dispatched crosshairs and
the team to go find them because he's
trying to get omega back
there's a crosshair across here cross
hair cross hair cross hair the singular
singular
that makes the most sense because it's
just solo per single person
yeah yeah um but then
you also have fenix shand and then you
have
uh bain here who are bounty hunters
higher to go
retrieve her so
who's this other person who's uh
yeah because it looks like they're
separate groups mm-hmm
it it felt to am i right about that am i
missing something here
it felt to me yeah like the imperial guy
the whose name eludes me now sent
crosshair
yes rampart sent crosshair and his
soldiers to apprehend and terminate the
bad batch
i thought he didn't care for them in the
beginning of this episode i thought he
was saying like what do i need them for
yeah so i i i to me that read like yeah
i don't i don't need any of them and i
don't need omega just go wipe
them out and then i've it read to me
like the kaminoans were like whoa crap
we need
omega still though so we'll send our own
guy to go and
retrieve her okay all right yeah that's
how it came across to me anyway i could
be a mystery
you're probably right uh yeah because
you know it's like crosshair
that's his outstanding mission that he
wasn't able to complete and clearly
they don't want these guys around i mean
like
part of that to me read like we don't
have use for them i don't want
those guys just wipe them out get me
what i need and go
you know and what did they what did
rampart need though
that's the part i'm less that's why i
thought rampart was like there's no need
to to even send people on a mission to
go take them out they're they're
they're not a threat even freaking uh
hunter when he comes face to face with
him is like why are you
why are you coming after us yeah what do
you what do we why do you need us
yeah why do you need to kill us that's
like i get why crosshair would
feel like i need to go after them but in
order to dispatch
you need like permission from a higher
up in order to bring all those troopers
with you
so uh yeah i don't know i feel like
there's like a line
that i'm just not remembering or that
totally slipped
i feel like i feel like the kaminoans
maybe protest and they're like no no
don't don't wipe them out we need
at least omega or something like that
and i feel like maybe that prompted the
whole line of like i don't care about
clones i don't need your clones you know
because omega is also a clone
but when i'm looking at fenix shannon
and she was hired by someone too
and she's also a bounty hunter bane
bounty hunter
and clearly fennec shan did not seem
like she was answering to the prime
minister
she said he's answering someone else and
i'm under the impression that
i mean with the way this episode's
edited when you cut back to the camino
people and then you go back cameron
owens and then you go
to here it's like oh it would look like
the prime minister hired
uh uh bane but
i'm like well wait a minute fenix shan
seemed like she's working for someone
else who also wants omega
yeah yeah so i don't know either way
it's
it's this was like a really cool episode
i love the music and it visually is
awesome
i thought it was getting a little bit
like repetitive in the first half
when crosstalk and then were coming toe
to toe with each other like really
coming face to face
i was very much in appreciation of it it
was hitting me of
didn't realize i kind of missed this
crosshair guy who else has seen this
dude
yeah well and they let him be away and
and not even addressed or mentioned
for several episodes it's been it feels
like it's been a while since last time
we saw him and i feel like that enhances
everything because
it makes i mean you know it's already
going to be personal but
uh it it is kind of it enhances that
feeling of being ambushed
yes well i think the show's been doing a
really good job in the last few episodes
of
really letting us feel the sense of
peril mm-hmm like that
tension like two episodes ago that was a
thing
that was like oh uh with the sisters
where
i really started to feel like yes
finally feeling like they're in danger
yeah and then last episode was a good
one where wrecker was going ballistic
here
and then in this episode i love that
they actually
lose at the end and the way they capture
that of of the pov
within hunter's helmet and how he's
seeing things and it's all disoriented
in his own head of like what was going
on and like the battles going on behind
bellerin
he's trying to get in there and you have
uh the devastation and the
worry of wrecker being like where's
where's omega you know i love that that
was a really cool ending
yeah and uh i i just appreciate that the
stakes are truly being felt and then
uh crosshair too
came getting all banged up was uh i
don't know there's something about that
that i'm not i don't even know why i
like that so much not because i don't
like crosshair there's just something
kind of rewarding about
seeing this like violent after effect in
a show like this
like when he's getting burned by the
engine and then it happened
seeing just how messed up he is
sometimes i it just makes it feel more
lived in i suppose
because sometimes i the physical stuff
these guys have to go through
doesn't seem like it has as much of like
a healing thing they have to
endure so to see him get like burnt up
and how messed up he looks
yeah it makes it feel more uh i don't
know if the right words are real
but there's something about it feels
more palpable
yeah it feels more tangibly harsh and
then you can imagine how that will
go to inform the growth of his character
because you know he's still
under the thumb of the empire and so
he's probably going to get pretty
jacked up in that whole pursuit and so
as
you know it's also cool because it's you
know a battle of wits between
him and his former cohorts and
everything and so he walks
away from it at all but very much worse
for the wear
and so yeah even though they don't
really have like a
they have a little bit of face to face
but not much of a direct
reunion like it feels like they are able
to leave a lasting
impact on him and i feel like that will
feed further conflict because you know
he's gonna have
whenever if ever crosshairs cross hair
is released from you know the chip and
inhibition and all that stuff he's going
to have these
scars and and battle wounds that were
brought on by his brothers you know so
like these are going to be reminders if
anything else you know once he's
if he's awake and woke awakened yeah
but overall i mean this was a fairly
simple
episode with just a really cool i was
okay i was uh
in the first i'm always appreciative of
how this show visually looks especially
in its darker aesthetic
and yeah i was i was enjoying it but i
wasn't
really hooked until like they finally
came face to face with cross hair again
yeah and then it started getting really
good and i thought like
how uh just just how um
uh i don't know what the right word is
that i'm looking for here i don't want
to just say the word ominous
uh but there is a yeah john foreboding
uh
that's another one dreadful dre
dread films it was dreadful well you say
dr tense
tense is another word we use a lot uh
tot
tot is a good one t-a-u-t tot yeah
that's a good one yeah it's another
tension
word yes as long as we just use a
synonym yeah we're okay
let's keep the thesaurus on hand
yeah no i i feel you though like the
further it gets into the episode and the
more you're
sort of i like that that that idea of
like okay well we know
they're jamming our signal so they must
still be on the ship and so everyone's
on the ship
but we don't know exactly where on the
ship and so it creates
a pretty palpable uh sort of
horror movie-esque sneaking around
kind of scenario and then you know you
end up inside a big old engine and then
you
you gotta wonder if they're gonna get
toy story threed at some point
um well that's what was cool about this
was it was an interesting
like cat and mouse game that they were
having
but in front of each other for so much
of it or like right
like in terms of the fight that they
were having of constantly have to having
to outwit one another
or um out yeah outsmart each other like
oh we're jamming the signals they're
jamming the signals
lead them here the crosshair probably
figured it out okay well if we blow this
we can go down there
all right nuke that engine but if we can
blow the engine we can go down here yeah
yeah there's a constant like trying to
up each other the whole time
yeah and one of those like problems
solving yeah in real time like uh
everything is reliant on the previous
decision for the next decision to happen
yeah yeah it was clever stuff uh overall
solid episode
enjoyed it and if anything the last few
minutes makes me
more excited about what's gonna happen
in the next episode per se
yeah it's cool i'm just glad bane's back
that's awesome well yeah and bringing
that
full-on you know star wars western flair
with him
that's what bane does man yeah yeah it's
nice badass
he's a badass character i think he's
like a fan favorite in a lot of ways
hey well comment below if you're excited
all right guys
bad batch episode eight leave your
thoughts down subscribe click that bell
hit that like button and we'll catch you
guys soon